hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing our 1858
match in london uh between paul charles
murphy and head
henry edward bird this is the second
game we'll be showing although it's not
most likely the second game of the match
as we mentioned not all games from the
match were recorded
only i i guess the the nicer ones and uh
here again morphe has the white pieces i
don't know why
they were uh saved in those in that
order but it's really really a lovely
one so i'm sure you're gonna enjoy it
so here uh continuing uh uh the the
match with bird uh one of uh
staunton's opponents and so far uh if
stoneton was
even considering facing morphy uh well
uh the the chances of that happening are
not
increasing the the more and more uh
players that that morphe beats
uh well i i don't know it just doesn't
seem like uh
staunton will get uh uh like inspired or
maybe
get get more interested in in facing
morphe but we'll see what happens we
still don't know
what's going to happen some of you do
but some of you don't
uh so uh continuing uh with with the
game uh let's check it out morphe has
the white pieces and again
continues with e4 and this game is
special for
for a few reasons uh we have e5 by bird
knight to f3
knight to c6 uh sorry about that
and bishop to c4 and here uh we have
bishop the c5 so the joko piano game is
on the board
uh and morphe plays b4 he goes for the
evans gambit and
this is the absolute best move you can
play in this position
i'm just i'm just kidding that this
wasn't played unfortunately
uh he went for c3 uh no i'm i'm kidding
again he actually
did play b4 and we will have the evans
gambit this game
so b4 is on the board we have bishop
captures on b4
and now c3 so the gambit has been
accepted and now
well there are several options as we
always say you can go to a5 you can go
here you can go here
uh it's even possible to go to d6 but
we're going to get back to that um
some other time so here bishop to c5 and
morphe strikes in the center with the d4
so again forcing black to decide what to
do here
we have e captures and c captures by
morphe you could also castle
but in those days i think that mostly uh
white would gambit another pawn if the
bishop retreated
on a5 then after captures he would
castle but here morphy just recaptures
would see captures on d4
and bishop back to b6 and now uh morphe
castle
so uh white sacrificed a pawn now black
has seven pawns white has six
and he's up in development and black has
to decide how to how to continue
development you can't
just play something like knight to f6 uh
because you uh well you make it too easy
for white just e5
and black is already in big big problems
so instead we have d6 here uh it's a
move you can never forget to play if
you're facing the evan's gambit so you
need to
take care of the e5 square and you need
to prepare to bring your light square
bishop into the game
so here we have d5 by morphe and now
knight backed not back but knight to a5
attacking the bishop on c4 knights the
e5 is also playable
however it doesn't seem all that great
for black if you just allow white to
capture so here
knight to a4 attacking the bishop and
morphy just
continues pushing in the center with e5
so it seems like it's a peace sacrifice
but not really because you always have
this queen a4 check
which will pick up the knight but this
is exactly what
with black plays so you could have
played something else for example bishop
to d3
is also a move but e5 was played by
morphe we have knight captures on c4
and now queen to a for check of course
morphy wants to
capture capture back the piece with
bishop to d7
help helping black develop and uh queen
captures on c4
and here we have d captures on e5 now
here knight the e7 is actually
what black should play because white
doesn't have a clear way of continuing
the attack you don't really have a way
of breaking through
i mean you could play something like e6
but it's not it's not all that great
just captures captures bishop c6 and
next movie you're gonna castle
and your bishop pair is definitely fully
operational here
so instead after this queen captures on
c4 move we have
captures on e5 instead of this uh well
safer
approach with knight to e7 and now
morphe captures on e5 and now black
still needs to
play one more move before he's allowed
to castle
and the problem with with a move like
knight to f6 then bishop to a3 comes
and you're never castling it it's just
completely lost for black
this always runs into d captures on c6
alpha
and after rook to e1 there's just no no
move for black to play
so instead after knight captures on e5
we have queen to f6
now with options of black castle in
queenside and here
bird says uh okay i don't mind you
capturing my my bishop here i'm gonna
capture with the king
with the king uh bring the rook into the
game and then just play king to c8 and
i'm gonna artificially castle queen side
basically
so here uh morphe does go for it we have
knight captures on the e5
king captures on the e5 and now comes
queen to g4
with check and what do you do here you
have to
you have to put your king somewhere and
any square other than
e8 is just gonna suffer a terrible fate
uh because you don't want to go on this
diagonal bishop to g5 just wins the
queen right away
so king to e8 and now comes bishop to g5
and this is a really interesting
position because your rook is hanging on
a1 uh rook to e1
always a possible check you could you
could try a lot of things
however morphe goes for bishop to g5 he
offers a full rook here so
can the rook be captured uh well both
long and short answer is no because if
you capture the rook
uh then you run into rook to e1 check
and there
there are no moves the queen slices this
way bishop also covers all of these
squares
your only move is to block or move the
king but it doesn't matter whatever you
do
now the queen switches sides queen to b
for check and the king has no moves
uh if you block with the knight just
captures with uh you know
continuing the attack so you could
prolong with c5
forcing white to capture our poisson but
it is just going to run into the same
defense so 97 queen captures with czech
king g8
and now a nice queen sacrifice to finish
the game with
rook captures on e8 so after bishop to
g5 we have queen to
g6 uh just getting the queen out of the
way and now
knight to c3 so in fact the rook was
never
open for grabbing uh and here uh black
has to decide what to do you you have a
well very uh very interesting moves like
h6
can you play it will you force black to
move uh not really because you always
have to keep an eye on the checks
because if
h6 you're going to play rook after e1
check and after the king moves then you
again have the
this queen check and you're not really
going to do anything but
black will be able to defend with queen
to d6 and this is okay for
for black because the queen is nicely
protected you don't have bishop to e7
the knight
covers that square and well
black is perfectly fine here but it is a
very complicated position
and probably bird wanted to
make it a little bit simpler so he
played knight to f6 instead again you
can't capture because the queen hangs
but uh here morphy goes rook eight to e1
he didn't play rook f the e1 uh in this
case because uh he wants this rook to
keep an eye on the f2 pawn
so instead rook ate the e1 with check
king to f8
and now queen to b4 with check king to
g8
now bird freed the g8 square as the
knight is now on f6 and here
uh morphy eliminates the defender of the
e4 square he goes bishop captures on f6
queen captures and knight to e4 bringing
the knight into the game
and now queen to g6 uh just getting the
queen out of harm's way
and now king to h1 an important move to
play because the bishop slices
all the way here and you should want to
you want to start playing this
point you want to play f4 f5 and maybe
even f6 at some point
so here h5 black does the same hopefully
he can play h4 h3 and queen capture some
g2 checkmate or
rather he will force white to defend
against the such threats
so f4 morphe continues uh with his plan
and h4 and now of course f5 attacking
the the black queen
we have queen to h5 and now we reach a
very interesting position where the
engine
is saying you have to play h3h3 is
extremely strong it's going to be very
helpful and you should play h3 but
morphe doesn't care
morphy plays whatever morphe wants he
plays the rook to f4
and now there are some very very
interesting tricks in this position
and black has to be very careful about
what he does here uh
so he could continue with something like
h3 uh but
it doesn't really work because now you
can even play g4 since the rook is on f4
or you can even play g3
that also works uh so h3 not
posing all that many problems you don't
have queen f3 check because the rook
covers that and you don't have any good
ways of
dislodging the rook so this uh
would be possible however there there
are other moves you can also try but
what you can't play is
what bird played and here uh bird played
f6 now i know you guys are already
allergic to
f6 but um uh you know he
he probably thought yeah i'm not gonna
allow him to play this pawn to f6
so i might as well stop it and now uh
it's all me now i'm just gonna counter
attack and crush morphy
but it doesn't work and it doesn't work
for a very specific reason
so uh feel free to pause the video and
find this winning idea for morphe while
i give you a couple of seconds
uh so for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on punishing this
f6 insolence idea and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's
knight captures on f6 with check and
this is beautiful because the king and
queen are in check
and you can either move the king and
well lose the queen or rather even if
you move the king is
just queen to e7 checkmate you don't
even have to worry about capturing the
queen the knight and the
pawn guard against any escapes so
g captures on f6 is the only move and
now
uh rook the g4 with check so you don't
really have any options here again if
you move the king is just checkmate
uh so you can't allow that uh here
uh bird decides to give up the queen so
queen captures on g4 was played
and now of course uh queen captures on
g4 so queen captures on g4
and king to f8 uh and now okay you do
have
two rooks and the bishop against the
queen and uh and the rook so it might be
playable if
the position was active for black
however your king is wide open and your
rooks are completely useless
not even connected uh so here rook the
e6 by morphe trying to make
quick work of his opponent uh but uh
uh not not a lot for for bert to do he
tried rook to h6 now guarding the f6
pawn but
just queen to f4 attacking the rook and
the rook can't really move from there
because
well you're going to lose this one and
the all the other squares are covered
so king g7 only move that guards the
rook but now comes
rook to e7 check and it was in this
position on move 31 that
henry edward bird resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
why is this so well after you play a
move you can't really play any move
because the rook is hanging so maybe a
counter attack
attacking white's rook now the problem
is that white can play
any any any moves he he can just move
the the
rook and then this rook is still under
attack he can even play the very
attractive d6
it's a wonderful idea because the rook
is hanging and you don't really have
you don't really have a move here if you
capture here you can just play this
the black rook is still hanging and once
you move it then it's just game over
you're gonna capture here with check
king g8 queen e6 check and now it's mate
in one king has to move the entire
seventh record
rank is covered and now queen to f7 uh
will be checkmate
uh so uh of course bird saw all of this
and after rook to e7 he resigned the
game
uh and yet another victory for paul
morphy who
after crushing uh every opponent he
faced so far
here in london uh is doing excellent and
is currently on a 100 winning streak
against henry bird
so we'll see how the match continues but
so far uh it's uh definitely all morphe
and this was uh
well uh the first game bird had a bit
more chances but here
uh he here he did hold his own but you
know after some point he
just he just fell apart and in that
regard he's not much different than
every other opponent morphy faced so far
uh so that's uh that's the game i do
hope you guys enjoyed it uh
i would like to thank warren evans
olympia david kimura assassin
and andrew hines for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
morphe saga checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day